joining us here on the program as
promised one of the Great's the goats
the man's got an Academy Award in the
trophy case and then you could check out
now his show that he is producing and
writing and hosting called detail on
ESPN plus he's Kobe Bryant how you been
Kobe I'm better for talking to you what
do you think LeBron James is thinking
when he wakes up today when he woke up
today in Cleveland oh we don't have a
breakfast after I guess he states his
hunger what do you think you know it's
uh it had so much experience it really
going down 1o in a playoff series it's
really not that big a deal I mean yeah
you look at the footage you know you'll
make the reads you'll make the
adjustments and you come back in Game
two ready to rock and roll so yeah I
don't think you sweating it why'd you
well I guess then let me hit the the
hammer a little bit closer to the to the
head of the nail here is is he thinking
about some of the open shots that his
teammates were missing I'm just
wondering what somebody at his level and
knowing about what the roster is and
what is to happen over the next couple
of days if not weeks
is he wondering if the parts are there
do you think he'll be well no yeah I
think what he's probably thinking about
is what are we doing in situations where
those jump shots aren't falling again
right so you try to control what you can
control so it's the team is having a
tough shooting night you know what can
you do offensive ly how can you position
those pieces on the floor where that
becomes a non-issue you know how do I
get them in situations we're now to get
layups at the realm because we're
carrying the threat of a shot on the
perimeter now there's different ways
that you can kind of you can play around
that it's not you know oh man and not
hitting shots we're done
it's figuring out what that second third
option is going to be when that's not
working and do you think he and all is
thinking about what his next step is
sure well not professional you know I
think he's thinking about what he's
gonna do in game two and would
adjustment he's gonna be making right go
from quarter to quarter and you make
those reads I think that's where it's
headed that Kobe Bryant five-time NBA
champion here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you think about the Sixers are
doing what how real do you think their
chances
they look phenomenal man I got you know
watching some of it on TV you can see
County electricity that's back in the
building which is a kind of reminded me
of going there for the playoffs myself
and you know it's just a fantastic sport
city and so to see the energy back in
the place right and embiid and what
Simmons is doing and you know the fats
they brought in and how well they all
the great job Brett's doing it's uh it's
fun to watch how sustainable do you
think this is for a run titles ya know
they can they can do it I mean you know
they they have length they have
athleticism you know they're active and
they move the ball very well they have
shooters just around Simmons and indeed
so I don't think this is a fluke by any
stretch of the imagination how do you
think Kobe that how Harden does what he
does by that I mean Charles Barkley last
night said he's one of the most
unguardable players of all time where do
you stand on that subject well I mean I
agree but not you know I you know it's
always funny to me to heal people for
allow superlatives writing that in that
fashion it's the way I look at the game
I just look at it from the next as an
old standpoint and you know this tray
instead he has and more importantly than
that how he developed some when you
first came to lead when he hellicksen
when he was in high school and then in
college it to where he is now and the
things that he's added right and he the
ability to not only play at the rim but
also to play on the right side of the
room his ability to hit the mid-range
he's always been able to shoot the long
ball but I think his ability to operate
in between the three and the basket that
development in this game is what's
really taking him to another level so
what do you thinks gonna win it off
Kobe let's get right down to it what do
you all know you know you know I don't
do that stuff man I don't know I try to
stay out of the business of player of
all energy man so you tell me you do not
have a crystal ball is what you know I
do not I do not have one and so I don't
know yeah he's gotta wait and see man
yeah we didn't see I don't know I don't
get into the prediction game much man I
just like watching these games go game
the game and trying to read the
adjustments that a team might make
to see what the counters are Tibet okay
so then let's talk about what counters
this Spurs might make knowing Popovich
as well as you do Kobe what do they have
any in their quiver here to try and stop
Golden State yeah the dangerous thing
about gold the stages that should always
two or three mistakes away for going
down 15 or 17 18 points right so you
have to be careful when you play against
them and play in the state free
basketball because you make a couple
mistakes at the wrong time and all of a
sudden the doors blow open right so you
have to minimize those mistakes right if
you you know come down dribble the ball
off your foot goes out of bounds going
to feed comes down hits a three alright
fluke accident happens whatever come
down make an errand pass they get a
still okay here's another three all
right we got to be careful with the ball
right come down take a shot missed a
shot from the corner ball balance
there's long all the sex goes go if a
goes down hits another three and all of
a sudden you're in a big hole but it
happens really really quickly so you
know San Antonio really has to be
careful with the ball have to make sure
they maximize each possession couple
more minutes left with good Kobe Bryant
here no I got you
Kobe Bryant here on the Rich Eisen show
first time I met you was that that was
in Bristol Connecticut SportsCenter
shoot me you and Stuart Scott remember
that one Kobe were you where you were at
the you walked in and you put some coins
in the machine and took out some chips
or something by just watching what's
your recollection Stewart personality
well y'all every every time I saw him he
always made it a point to talk about
North Carolina and how I would have
looked great that door fell out of move
never never never never ever especially
you can always you know I was talking
about Duke galati's I thought that Duke
blue where look good on you you sort of
saying but you know you're such a
pioneer man you know watch them frame
and got through the league and the
things that he would say and he kind of
set the standard of how covering a game
could be just as entertaining as
somebody playing it and you know it's
just uh just an unbelievable legend man
so did Dean Smith try to bring you there
that what had it well yeah he sent me a
letter which I still have to this day
was the funniest letter man yeah he said
I think this would be a great place for
you blah blah blah and he said oh he
said but from everything that I hear and
from watching you play I think you'll go
straight to the NBA so if you ever
change your mind you know where to find
me all right cool and then he put down a
PS stop wearing out stack how annoying I
kept that letter is this before you say
it a little bit so did any school come
close to making you come to campus for
even a year or suit or - oh no I don't
want to waste your time you know I felt
like that would've been wrong you know
they have you know other athletes out
there that they're recruiting I didn't
want to take up a slide when I knew I
was just going to go straight to the NBA
so I didn't want to waste anybody's time
with that you know I kind of let him
know but it was still some great
experiences man I remember talking to
Indiana or Kansas it was Kansas and I'm
on the phone when a guy goes you know
I'm uh it's so beautiful I like oh he
will love it like I'm driving right now
I got cornfield elastics all right I'm
like man dude I'm like in the city right
now and I don't know anything about a
couple more minutes with Kobe Bryant
here detail on ESPN plus we'll get to
that one one second I do want to ask you
where's your Academy Award right now
where is that located I have it at home
and I have it at home until uh you know
we're supposed to be moving out his
office here in a little bit and then we
can have a safer office I'll probably
put it in there I have it sitting right
next to the ante awards at the antiwar
in Oscars I'll look at more okay so then
what's next I mean how many projects do
you have granite II Studios and now that
you have an animated short film Oscar
what else what else what are you picking
through scripts I mean what is it like
right now for you no I mean we're
writing company we're creative companies
so we we come up with the concepts
internally
okay and and then we make them right and
so their basketball is one of them and
now we have detail that's on now and
then we follow that up with a really fun
chosen podcast for sports it's really
really fun I can't wait to share more
about that and then the final year in 19
the first quarter will be coming out
with our first novel and that's a
basketball series now filled with fun
sports and magic so so we've been busy
so I mean when Wednesday music and/or
Broadway hitting because I assume the
idea is to get the Tony and the am ian
and the Grammy to go with everything
else right that's the idea right no idea
just to make good stuff man you know we
really behave with a kind of a pinpoint
focus on on on children and athletes you
know and trying to teach them life but
through the game you know how you pay
attention to details no discipline you
know the hard work leadership teamwork
camaraderie all those little lessons
that you know kids you know I mean kids
just tuned us out like s parents we keep
telling that stuff yeah they just tune
us out man so like okay well we as
parents we might we need stories to read
them stories that they can listen to
that has everything to do with sports
but also everything to do with the
lessons that we want to teach them that
they're tired here for us so that's what
I try to infuse everything with well
then before I let you go here Kobe it
with detail and everything else your
perfect person asked this just yesterday
well you know Suzy you she covered yeah
for many many years I thought she wanted
me to say the same thing to you but our
our seven-year-old for the first time
yesterday while I'm throwing wiffle
balls to him got competitive and wanted
to beat me for the first time and I'll
never forget it was now obviously I'll
have the date and of the time it already
etched in my brain what do you suggest I
do to stoke that competitive flame try
to beat on what do you think here Kobe
what should I go you yeah well you know
you know that he wants to beat you at
the thing is your job as a father to put
him in a situation we can learn how to
do that and it's just day by day day by
day by day right so you're not obsessive
with the results but becomes obsessed
with the process that then leads to the
result and yeah that's what I try to do
a fight my daughter and seeing them
festival while playing basketball so we
just going through the process every day
we just work on skills and just keep
kind of chopping a tree and then they
learn that and hope you're sad
when you beat you know it so it comes
for all fathers man that avoidable the
Sun rising tomorrow - taxes is South
Beach they'll go to the day that are
consistently it's interesting that it
happened to me on tax day than yesterday
Kobe on the fifteenth of right so before
I let you go again detail tell folks
about how they can go about watching you
breakdown games from your past as well
as current games in the playoffs right
now yeah well detail you'll find on if
you don't a TS p.m. platform you click
on ESPN Plus that's what you'll find the
show detail and what you'll see on
details you'll see me assuming the
personality of one of the players like
the second episode that we just came on
here last night I'm looking at Game one
of the Toronto and wizard series as if I
were to barter Rosa so if I was the
[ __ ] I just got finished playing this
game how would I study that game that I
just played and how would I in turn take
what I've learned from Game one to try
to apply it for Game two so you know
that's what this whole series is going
to be Kobe Congrats on the Oscar
Congrats on this on an incredible career
and I'd love to have you up in studio
whenever you're in the LA area I
appreciate a rich man thank you very
much you got it that's Kobe Bryant at
Kobe Bryant on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience